[Music]
[Music]
friend
oh
[Applause]
uh
[Music]
oh
ronnie what do we got we got units
headed out there now you're missing
firebox
i think i'll play
[Music]
oh my god it's okay it's okay we're okay
we're okay
that'll happen a bomb
i think
[Music]
i don't know why he came all the way up
here
there's nothing left
there are people out there
people worth saving
most people had finally given up hope
[Music]
[Applause]
uh
[Music]
let's go
quiet please part two picks up right
where quiet place part one
left off the idea of these kids and this
family dealing with their safety net
being taken from them
evelyn is now a single parent newborn
baby
the barn's burnt down the house is
destroyed and she's out there on her own
and she has to protect these children
they are forced to go out into the world
and see how other people live
so they literally leave the path of
safety and go into the unknown
[Music]
it's harrowing it's terrifying but at
the core of it it's a very human
story i don't know why you came all the
way up here
there's nothing left please
she's just trying to keep everybody
alive and discover that there's other
people out there
and the world changes in an instant
there are people out there worth saving
you don't know do you i do
we answer all those questions that the
audience was asked about day one
especially how did this all start
every step is much more treacherous it
definitely ratchets up the tension and
you know they're not safe
[Music]
you